WOOHOO!!!!
Hey, Aaron, is it just me, or
is this year’s Quarter-Season Carnival…
kinda soft?
Sir, you’re going to have to leave
Noooo
I love quarterbacks
I’m sorry
Hey look, guys
I finally hit the target!
I’m sorry
I know everyone’s rooting for me
Don’t worry
The Colts will help you win!
OH, I’M PATTY MAHOMES
AND I SHOOT REAL GOOD
Come ride Booger McFarland’s Sideline Machine!
WELL, THE CONDITIONS HERE
AT THE CARNIVAL ARE VERY SCARY
Sir, you’re up
Nope. Not yet.
Man, where’s Eli?
He said he’d connect with us here
HELP! I’M NOT A MOBILE QB!
I’M OLD AND SCARED
God damn-
Odell, you’re polite now, remember?
I love dealing with Eli
I can’t move my feet!
ELI! WHERE ARE YOU?!
I won’t leave my corn pocket
A PASS-RUSHER
LOOKING FOR A PASS-RUSHER!
ANY QUARTERBACKS!
I’M LOOKING FOR ANY
NON-CONTROVERSIAL QUARTERBACKS!
ANYBODY ON THE STEELERS!
WHERE YOU AT!
Shhhhhhh
Don’t tell
No siree, Bob
that maze is too tricky for me!
WOW, WHAT A FUN, EASY MAZE
Subscribe to this channel
Watch more episodes
I gotta go